[Applaus] Nikita Milla ja das ist schon also
da muss auch sagen ja ich weiß auch nicht also
ich habe eine Sand gehört hinten und da war ich
gedanklich doch wieder bei der CSU da habe ich mir
gedacht nee also man kann nicht sagen ja ja also
es gibt schon Unterschiede oder zwischen der Mafia
hat einen Ehrenkodex aber es ist wirklich
es ist toll es ist toll die Markus Söder
alles also wie er Bayern und die CSU in
einem man kennt es von früher 8 Klasse
Biologie Bayern und sehe so das ist so
bisschen wie Symbiose zwischen Baum und
fils Pilz Entschuldigung Pilz und der glatt
blättrige Knollen Knöterich auch bekannt als
en lassen haben sie mir gerade die
Freunde mit dem Söhne kaputt gemacht
auch lassen sich nicht stören
aber ich wollte nur sagen also
also auch bekannt als sabbernde ich gehe
södermorchel einer musste hier was schaffen
ne ist durch sein Myzel im Untergrund mit den
Wurzeln seines Stammes verbunden also mit dem
Freistaat und auf den ist er ja Herrmann wenn sie
es noch mal auf den ist er doch immer so stolz hat
er doch am Filz gedenkt da also am Aschermittwoch
in Passau so schön gesagt weiß blau Stadtgrün wow
wir sind kein gendernder Zwangsstaat wir sind
ein Freistaat liebe Freundin liebe Freunde
die klimakleber also mal eben 30 Tage in
Präventivhaft genommen man gut das ist halt
auch also ein Freistaat also das ist auch also
Bayern also alle weil Bayern ist aber da geht
es weil Bayern ist ein Freistaat der immer also
immer was zu meckern hat Richtung Berlin mehr
lassen uns von Berlin nicht vorschreiben was
richtig und gut ist für unser Land der andere
Freistadt Sachsen ist auch so Sachsen ist endlich
drauf auch das wird immer gemotzt und gejammerte
kommen die aus Berlin und wollen uns vorschreiben
lassen muss man zu dünnen zu lassen haben das geht
nicht wir sind Freistadt also im Grunde verstehen
sich beide also Bayern und Sachsen also die den
Rest der Republik als er lästiges Anhängsel
sehen als Abtrünnige Separatisten Gebiete die
endlich als Volksrepubliken anerkennt werden
möchten Freunde also also lass es nicht den
Putin hören am Ende kommt ja noch kommt er noch
auf den Geschmack und [Musik] wäre schade um
die Alpen das habe ich neulich in Bautzen gesagt
mein lieber Gott ich hatte einen Shitstorm danach
wollen Sie damit sagen das ist übrigens Sachsen
nicht so schade wäre bloß weil er keine Alpen
habe ich doch gar nicht gesagt aber
aufpassen müsst ihr schon ein bisschen
mit eurem Ministerpräsidenten Kretschmer oder
wie immer hinter vorgehaltene Hand immer gern
sagt das Putin Liebchen also wie er sich anwandt
an den Kreml so als könnte es gar nicht erwarten
endlich Teil der Russischen Föderation zu
werden und wenn jetzt Putins also Blutung
der kadiros der schon gesagt hat also sie
hätten auch Ansprüche auf die Ostgebiete
vorsicht also wenn Putin jetzt auf die Idee käme
im Zuge einer militärischen spezialoperation zu
sagen wir marschieren in Dresden nein
um Sachsen von den Nazis zu befreien
da hat er aber Zeit lang zu tun
[Applaus]